[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to pivara
today I'll be working on some detailing
for the ride in general and getting some
more steampunky elements into the ride
because I haven't really done that too
much in the last couple of episodes and
also doing some quirky stuff like the
supporting of pipes of the ride
mostly because I had to remove the
in-game supports because there isn't
actually any ground underneath this so
I'm trying to put supports together
using the I primitives which actually
goes extremely well and I'm actually
really happy with how well this actually
works to be quite honest supporting
roller coasters has always been one of
my favorite things getting into this so
many years ago with roller coaster group
3 where it was very much the custom that
everybody would custom support roller
coasters and the same goes for no limits
even though I've I've barely done that
as much but it's something which can be
a lot of fun and it isn't really
possible for too many of the rights in
planet coaster given the hitboxes that
they have but the this coaster type is
the one exception where you can actually
have the custom support pieces or in
this case the art primitive pieces or
any scenery piece for that matter
connect with the track of the coaster
actually go through it for a little bit
so you can actually make custom supports
for this coaster emitters also moves not
in the least because it means that I can
actually have some track over here which
isn't completely floating but I would
love to actually experiment a little bit
more with supports at some point in a
future I want to give a huge shout out
already to free the bear who I've talked
about in his latest quali bridge and in
part tutorial but I just want to do it
again because he made an intimate mega
lights a few months ago which was one of
the first fully custom supported
coasters in planet coaster or well this
is really fully custom supported but for
major stretches it is custom supported
and it brings a completely different
look to the
and to the coaster in general because
you actually have that extra added
element of creativity of making me
support to look good and also
structurally sound and I thought that
was one of the most innovative rides on
that sort of topic since there isn't too
much going on with custom supporting and
planet coaster because it is something
that takes a lot of time and also
knowledge of how rollercoasters are
actually supported
don't get me wrong I am super glad that
planet coaster actually has some good
in-game supports but custom spawning can
be a lot of fun and I think there's a
lot of creativity to be seeing in there
as well so I just had a small experiment
with that but I'll return to those
supports at some later stage for now
though I also want to very quickly get
to some supporting of the coaster over
here and this is a bit different because
it's the helix that is sticking out at
the back of the island and in fact we
have three sort of half helix is over
here which are sticking out and that's
one reason why this was a major struggle
for me in any case since I didn't want
to extend the island be beyond this
point since I really thought that would
make the island way too large but I also
had to make sure that these tracks are
actually being supported and so what I
figured I could do is actually have a
huge sort of suspended machinery rail
going underneath the track I know it
makes barely any sense but this was just
something I figured was about the only
thing to get somewhat structurally sound
supports underneath the coaster without
it taking in a lot of space and then
eventually actually suspend the entire
construction using cables from a sort of
crane that's hanging on top of it but
I'll get into that later as well but for
now we have that entire construction
with some custom supports and the metal
over here what was also kind of fun
about this is that the supports are
loosely based on actual intamin supports
this is realistically an intimate roller
coaster and it's an intimate hyper
coaster kind of like
it's of the same type as millennium
force or if you're European you might
relate to expedition g-force more or
cellulitis in the Netherlands and it's
an interesting type because it has you
know it's every kind of company as their
own look to their supports and this can
be very subtle but you can definitely
tell a different kind of coarser types
and different kind of coastal
manufacturers have a different looking
support system and for intamin they have
those typical connectors to connect the
supports to the track which kind of
stick out and that's that's one of the
one of the things I actually wanted to
get back into this coaster as well so
that even though it is a floating
coaster it still has some of the touches
that makes it a somewhat realistic
intimate even though you can probably
scrap that idea as a whole since it's on
the floating islands and the layout is
of course ridiculously compact I still
wanted to get some of those touches in
there because might as well and at this
point I wanted to do a lot of detailing
and partly I wanted to leave a lot of
this detailing of the time lapses
because it's all very similar but this
part I didn't want to remove because I
thought it was kind of fun and it's
making a steam machine on the bottom of
support now steam machines are one of
the only ways in which I can actually
get some machinery into this coaster
being a steam punk coaster and to be
fair I didn't really have any idea in
mind when I was building this machine
what kind of function it would have I
was just figuring that standard supports
were just kind of looking too boring and
also the supports without any scenery
around it we're kind of liking the
connection to the rest of the island and
I really wanted to draw in the supports
into the theme as well and so I kind of
had this idea of slowly gradually
building it up from very steampunk
details and spires which a steam machine
actually worked quite well for so that
was something that I didn't want to get
in here and obviously what it also gives
you a next
spore is once you have that machine you
can actually have all the pipes and all
of the gears and everything around it to
have a lot of interesting detail to look
at on the sides as well it also kind of
gave this little platform a function
which I was very very happy to do since
I was having a really hard time coming
up with a function for this small
platform it was hanging empty on the
side of the island for quite a while and
I'm actually quite glad that I'm able to
actually fill in something over here
also I haven't set this yet but a lot of
the things that I've done outside the
videos since last episodes were just in
live streams I've done a couple of live
streams where I just randomly doodled
away at the island mostly doing some
detail work but also a lot of filling in
work so there were a lot of these sort
of empty messy clustered areas in the
middle of the of the island where all
sorts of buildings would come together
in a jumbled mess and a lot of that is
basically cleanup at this point and we
also have some extra details some extra
pipes and also to stuff on the side of
the walls and everything so that we
don't have to do too much of that
anymore but the more I work on this
thing the more I do realize that going
through with this kind of level of
detail is going to take quite a while
hence also why the episodes have been
very infrequent I'm sorry about that
I really want to finish this thing as
quickly as I can but it's just quite
difficult to actually do that with the
amount of stuff that I'm putting in here
thankfully though and I guess that's
kind of thankfully in terms of actually
doing this efficiently I am starting to
get used to all of the pieces quite a
lot so it doesn't so much take a lot of
time anymore to have to experiment with
the pieces all the time kind of know
where all the pieces are located and how
they kind of work together so the
workflow is kind of speeding up in that
sense but still it does say quite a
while to get all of these details in now
here we have a message which you haven't
seen before a lot of this was built on
streams if I recall correctly there's
a huge section over here which was kind
of cleaned up with walls and we also
have the sort of stone catwalks on the
side of the coaster and I think it the
one last thing to make this more
interesting would be a head chopper over
your head as you're flying down this
hill don't mind the brakes too much
they're just trim brakes without those
the rest of the layouts are slightly too
fast but they don't break down the
coaster a lot and I thought having this
moment over here we just kind of deep
dive into this hole almost crashing to
the ground on the other side would be
very interesting and with having all of
these all of the walls and the pipes on
the top of that little bridge going over
the coaster so close together to the
track kind of makes it seem a little bit
faster and also helps to fill up the
area as well this was quite honestly one
of the most difficult areas to fill in
when it comes to the coaster since it's
very tight and it's at times kind of
difficult to actually fit everything in
between these spaces I'm also just
hanging a few cables here in there so
that general detailing to make
everything look a little bit more dark
and gritty that was a very recurring
comments that I got for many people
which is very sir and I'm really happy
to get it as well like I'm super far
from perfect and any comments that I can
get any criticism being positive or
negative can always help and a lot of
the things which came back was that the
pivara island was missing a lot of the
grittiness that some of the earlier
episodes had and especially with all of
the pipes but also these darker textures
and also too little machinery the the
cables hanging from the building's
everything that's very messy and well
really chaotic purposely is something to
hopefully get that Christian book back
into it now I'm just finishing off some
of the pipes over here to also get some
detailing into these towers and that is
really almost it for this area what I by
the way he thought was very interesting
is that during this coaster I've really
gotten some extra love for all of the
Christmas candies and cookie items
since some of the cookies actually play
a role as any kind of like detailing on
the walls that's that's kind of the
funny thing about making details like
that at some point I was just randomly
sticking items into walls and just see
whatever would stick pretty much into
some of the cookies and candies actually
have some very very good unique textures
that you can use for these kinds of
things so the waffles for instance have
that almost sort of metallic look to it
that you otherwise have to sing some
animatronics into the ground for for
instance or the round cookies not
entirely sure what they're named
actually can give you some of those
round shapes which is sometimes very
hard to get into
so yeah especially in terms of shapes
and textures giving the candies
different colors and they're supposed to
mean kind of sinking them into things to
experiment a little bit with them can
give you so many different users beyond
just being simple candies that it's kind
of like the gingerbread decorations in
that way they are the Christmas
decorations but just by virtue of adding
new shapes and textures to play with in
the game they actually open up all kinds
of new possibilities anyway that was my
little rant about candies in this game
one of the last things that I wanted to
get into was the crane to actually
suspend the cables from that are going
to supports the cursive supports and the
helix and I was actually struggling with
this thing a pretty embarrassing amount
trying to get it in in such a way that
it didn't look too heavy that it was
dwarfing the cables that I was trying to
hang the entire construction from while
at the same time not making it so small
then it seems like the entire thing was
just unstable and especially the
connection from the crane to the actual
cables is still a pretty difficult thing
and definitely something that I might
want to experiment a bit more with as
well but for now I just decided to leave
it the way that I did which is with this
round crane a small little connection
points where all of the different cables
are hooking onto and then they're
hooking into the
entire line of all sorts of gears and
stuff I also realized what you see on
the outside of the gears is actually a
candy piece as well that's one of the
card
I forgot the English name for it hold up
I am actually in a game
let me check right now it's one of those
marshmallow pretty sure it is just
marshmallow pieces yeah yeah okay it's
one of the marshmallow pieces which is
very interesting because they they have
those sort of pink baby blue yellowish
colors from themselves but if you make
them really dark they actually get this
sort of metallic shine and they also
have the general shape of a vertical
gear so I was kind of figuring your mind
as well make some like machinery pieces
out of that stuff anyway that's just
random ideas that I'm smoking in the
video but it was the kind of general
idea then I had with this with as little
parts on the outside of the ring
supporting the coaster say that was some
pretty interesting stuff and finally the
time lapse is closing off with some very
general detailing again hopefully we're
getting some little steps closer to
finishing this ride I'm still not
entirely sure how many new episodes it's
going to take especially since I don't
want to feature all of this in episode
since it is quite the same so I'm
probably going to end up doing quite a
bit of this off screen or in streams and
stuff like that my end goal is finishing
for vara and how we're going to get
there is obviously a little bit of a
smaller worry for me at this time this
is also my only solo projects in Planet
Coast right now and I've got so many
ideas for things that I want to try that
I'm hopefully I can get this over in a
little bit of a quicker way than I would
if I had to record everything for an
episode and we'll move into some other
things but for now thanks for watching
and I will see you guys in the next
episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]